recently outside of my house I had a
bunch of crows 20:30 crows all in one
tree just calling non-stop for about two
days straight just day and night
non-stop shaking the tree all at once so
finally I called animal control and I
was like hey what the hell is going on
with these birds they said it's baby
crow season they're calling it the baby
crows until they learn to fly and that
can last up to five days and I was like
what
that's the crow flight training program
that's a teach the gift of flight for
five days and it works five days that
we're gon try it at home on your kids
taking it too far with cows we kill them
we eat them we wear them that's on par
with most animals but with cows we also
eat veal which are their children then
we drink their milk doesn't sound as bad
but it's the milk intended for their
children we hate we eat their babies and
then we eat their babies food
with cookies Duncan cookies in there but
then on top of all of that we take
pictures of our missing children hey
sorry for killing your kid haven't seen
my kid though really worried about my
kid your kids dead ate him washed him
down with his own food people look out
for my kid turned 30 recently still
can't figure out how to turn off ceiling
fans can't do it go up to a ceiling fan
[Music]
if we start listening for the noise like
[Music]
and to manually stop it's like Danny's
you come over to my house in the middle
of winter all the ceiling fans are on
it's like hey man which are for ceiling
fans I know I can't actually that's why
I brought you over three clicks seven I
don't know I don't understand why
refrigerator door ice machines are so
loud it's so embarrassing to cool your
drink at someone else's house everyone's
a living room watching a movie you go in
the kitchen just like one ice cube is
one ice cube finally just give up you
just open the freezer there's just an
already made pile of ice in there what
the hell is the noise I thought was at
least making the ice what's happening in
there just a tiny robot just kicking
around ice
slide it down the tube found out there's
people that don't believe in dinosaurs
they think that the devil put dinosaurs
owns in the earth to trick us
which is the lamest nerdiest devil ever
he's just some science-fiction nerd
devil like hey Lucifer what's on the
agenda for tonight famine plague
genocide no actually a much more
diabolical scheme I've created a
prehistoric reptilian species I'm gonna
take their bones and bury them deep down
in the earth as you suggest an alternate
timeline than in the Bible and then
we'll hope that one day someone comes
along digs them up any questions God's
existence
and if that doesn't work we still have
the gays hey thanks for watching be sure
to click subscribe to see even more
great Conan clips you may now return to
your pirated movies and creepy Japanese
pornography